Jason it seems like to you marketing a
film as exciting I see a spark in your
eyes when you talk about it for many
people that are filmmakers artists
whatever I think their ears probably
shut off when they hear the word
marketing probably as exciting as
getting a telemarketing job or working
in something relating to that what can
someone do to make it interesting they
have to do it themselves let's say they
don't have the money for publicist
whatever and what are some what's it
what's a little cheat sheet in this day
and age 2013 what can they do to market
their film on their own no money just
their own time sweat equity behind the
computer I mean I would say you know if
you're at the stage where you're making
a movie and you don't have any money
from marketing see this is this is a
little bit tough for me to answer
because I would say at that point it's
time to do a crowdfunding campaign the
reason I bring up a crowdfunding
campaign is because it's gonna it's
gonna teach you to be a marketer it's
gonna teach you to go out and do all the
things that you mentioned that they kind
of make people shut down which is in a
sense your telemarketing your calling
your friends saying like look I'm doing
this crowdfunding campaign I got to
raise X number of dollars so I can
create this advertising you know execute
on this advertising strategy or whatever
you you know I have to raise a marketing
budget even if it's a few thousand
dollars I need something to kind of
grease the gears you know so I would say
if you don't have any money that maybe
it's time to think about a crowdfunding
campaign it'll teach you to be
entrepreneurial and teach you to do some
of the things that you find to be a
little bit uncomfortable but the flip
side of it is it'll teach you whether or
not your movie has a really strong
concept it'll teach you whether or not
your movie promotes word-of-mouth
there's been several crowdfunding
campaigns and I'm sure everybody
watching this they can reference where
they were like that's really cool I have
to fund that you don't know the
filmmaker you don't you know you didn't
know anything about the story but yet
you heard about this thing and you
thought that looks interesting I got to
do that when you have that feeling about
a project that means something in that
project strikes a chord with you either
the pitch is really good or the actual
content of the movie or the emotional
draw it's there and it's driving you
it's pulling you in
so crowdfunding allows you to tap
your film before you dive in both feet
first or jump in both feet first if you
don't do a crowdfunding campaign and you
find yourself like like I have on some
of my early movies where you're out
there and you're like oh man I created
this movie and I have nowhere to go with
it then it's just take a look at what
the movies about cut a trailer that
appeals to a certain target demographic
and try to get all of your messaging
consistent consistent they talked a lot
about branding up that's probably
another one of those terms that makes
people shut down but in short branding
is the idea of matching your belt with
your shoes there should be some
consistency in all of your marketing
there should be a general tone to
everything that you produce around your
movie your poster in some way should
feel like the cousin to your trailer and
your trailer should feel in some ways
the cousin to your website and your
website should feel in some ways the
cousin to your Twitter campaign and your
your Facebook page for your movie those
are some of the very easy things and I
will say you know one of the things
we're developing at chill is a turnkey
solution for all of this it's called
insider access and what it allows you to
do is create a narrative around the
making of your movie so each piece of
content that you create like I'm
thinking about casting this actor today
I wonder which one I should pick you can
be talking to your audience you can be
growing that audience within insider
access
collecting email addresses having shares
set up then if somebody comes in there
and they like the content they share it
out somebody else sees it they come back
they now opt and they become part of
your fan base and you continually engage
them from start to finish I know that
was a long-winded answer so just to kind
of recap do crowdfunding campaign and at
the same time if you're looking for a
tool set reach out to me over a chill
and ask me about insider access how do
they contact they can contact me Jason
at chill comm oh great okay
you